las juventudes palestinas marcan el
camino en nablus grupos de jóvenes se
reúnen en brigadas para alzarse en armas
en contra del ejército israelí No
pertenecen directamente a facciones más
grandes como jamás sin embargo colaboran
con ellas para facilitar el control de
territorios y evitar la detección por
autoridades israelíes muchos de los
integrantes han perdido seres queridos
En el conflicto lo que ha causado que en
su imaginar la lucha armada sea la única
salida
estamos todos aquí la brigada al Axa la
alcut y la brigada alcázame han matado a
mis dos hermanos pero todos los que
están aquí son mis hermanos ganaremos
todos los días con cada martes que muere
ganaremos diez en su lugar tan solo en
2023 alrededor de 80 palestinos han
perdido la vida a manos de las fuerzas
armadas israelíes en constantes redadas
además los asentamientos de colonos y
israelíes en territorios palestinos
considerados ilegales por la mayoría de
los estados de la comunidad
internacional provocan Un aumento
constante de las tensiones
no hay miedo miedo de qué de la muerte
Los enfrentamos a ella todos los días
cuando caminamos por la calle nos
enfrentamos a la muerte de qué debería
tener miedo debería llevar mi arma y
enfrentarme al ejército Porque pueden
dispararme mientras estoy en casa
los movimientos nacionalistas palestinos
post han sido liderados históricamente
por jóvenes y estudiantes en la Segunda
intifada del 2000 este sector
poblacional fue un Rebelde protagonista
en las manifestaciones ahora los jóvenes
palestinos cansados de abusos abren la
posibilidad de una tercera Revolución
popular Palestina